sequel itis it's a condition Godzilla
king of the monsters
so Godzilla king of monsters is the
sequel to the 2014 Godzilla movie
explaining the plot I can either explain
it from the Titans perspective or the
humans perspective I'm gonna stick with
the Titans because it's just a little
more clean and concise basically after
Godzilla and another huge monster
leveled San Francisco now people know
that these Titans have existed they are
real and they're out there but they're
in the state of hibernation
now Godzilla's gonna throw down with
another one to see who's top dog pretty
much it also there are human beings some
have good intent some have malicious
intent and I'm just gonna cut right to
the chase the first movie was better and
by the first movie I mean like what the
23rd Godzilla movie but for the sake of
this movie being a sequel to the last
movie I'm gonna call it the first movie
2014 Godzilla I just thought it was
better create a 2014 Godzilla I feel
like was devices but I don't know how
devices because everyone I know like in
life my actual friends people I interact
with like in the physical world not
through the internet we all really liked
the last Godzilla movie there were
people online though who were like I
didn't like it it didn't show Godzilla
enough but it teased him but then he
only showed up at the very end to do
some stuff and get that complaint but I
see why they did it the way they did it
and that Godzilla movie and after seeing
Godzilla king of the monsters I really
understand why they went that route with
the last Godzilla movie so I will give
this movie that it listened to fans who
wanted to see more Godzilla yes see more
of them in this movie you wanted to see
Godzilla fight more monsters you see
more of that and this movie
Aaron taylor-johnson from 2014 Godzilla
was to onenote now you have Kyle
Chandler in this movie and this dude
does everything he's not OneNote he is
literally everything he knows a lot
about this piece of tech he's along for
the ride if there's an away team he's on
that away team anyone has a question
about something he has the answer anyone
has an answer to something he has a
counter that's actually the correct
answer if there was a military tactic
that needs to be decided in a room full
of military personnel including
commanders and the like he's the one
who's gonna be like no no don't do that
do this other thing because I know
better than you do and they're like
alright but is it for the best that's
the question I just don't think it was
yeah you see more fighting in this movie
but whereas the last Godzilla movies
there was a build-up and you're like oh
again with the airport the foot at the
airport I was like I wish I saw that
fight I don't like seeing the aftermath
undeniably though by the end of the
movie there was a lot of payoff because
you're like finally we're seeing that
thing that's been built up all this time
there's a huge release with it this
movie by the end you're like monsters
fighting scene and where's the fighting
in this movie was more plentiful none of
the fights were as impressive as the end
fight in the previous Godzilla movie
some of the moments in the fight
sequences they were really messy - just
like in terms of [ __ ] getting thrown on
the screen the framing of the fight
there's no good steady shot with both
the monsters in the frame so you can
actually tell what's really happening
the camera can I call it a camera it's
not actually camera the monsters are CGI
but there were more than a few moments
where the monsters were closer to the
cameras and they probably should have
been when they were fighting in terms of
visual appeal there are quite a few
shots and here you're like that looks
amazing it's usually right before a
clash happens like the round one fight
moment be like that looks majestic it's
like a poster or a wallpaper look
fantastic and then the clash happens
you're like oh yeah all right here we
are doesn't mean this movie doesn't have
some impressive stuff for some moments I
was like those pretty kick-ass it's rad
impressive it's fanservice again I
didn't grow up on Godzilla or anything
like that so when I see those fanservice
moments I'm like I know that's a
fanservice moment which means fans are
gonna go nuts I'm just watching the
movie as a guy who enjoyed the last
Godzilla movie now I'm watching the
sequel I'm completely oblivious to
Godzilla I'd seen some movies when I was
younger it's mainly like hey but what
the princess is in another castle she's
not gonna save herself or if not
fanservice moments that tie in the
monster cinematic universe is it's two
movies it's Godzilla and King Kong is
that enough to make a cinematic universe
one is you see those building blocks in
this movie - if you're a fan of it
you'll think that's pretty cool so I
guess that's the thing right there
that's the point to keep in the pocket
if you're a Godzilla fan who wants to
see some Godzilla fanservice who saw the
previous Godzilla movie and you're like
and I want to see more Godzilla this
movie's going to give that to you but
that that is classic sequel itis right
it's like it gives you more but bigger
isn't always better unless you're
talking about representation of size
scale of which I think Gareth Edwards in
his previous Godzilla movie did the
scale representation better than they
did in this movie in the 2014 Godzilla
movie Godzilla moved really slow because
the bigger stuff to use
slower it appears to move this movie
Godzilla and the other monsters they're
very quick and nimble compared to how
big they're supposed to be it just makes
them look smaller than they should look
and I think this movie has a bit of
identity crisis some of the dialogue is
laughably bad in that way we're like but
maybe it's supposed to be cheesy there's
a line - people make this line in tandem
it's like this oh my god Zilla I mean
it's in here and that's not even the
biggest one that makes you like are they
doing this on purpose but doesn't commit
to that so you don't know if they're
trying to be a cheesy 90s action movie
or they're trying to elevate the genre
somehow and take it more seriously you
don't really know it tries to do both so
guys in the end Godzilla king of the
monsters has some enjoyment in it but
the plot was kind of sloppy and messy
throughout it's like they were like
let's have monsters fight we'll just
kind of build a bit of a plot around it
does it work kind of but monsters fight
it's bigger it's grander so it's gonna
come down to opinion as to whether or
not that means better I personally just
don't think it did in fact it would be
more fun if I were drunk yeah now it's a
party the fact is if I want to see two
beings fight to see who's top dog I'll
just watch Wentworth not sponsored just
a good show and this next thing this
isn't a slight on the movie at all I'm
just literally saying this to [ __ ] with
you this is the only reason but once you
see this you're not gonna unsee it
that's why I'm saying it when Godzilla
and Ghidorah fight try not to think of
Mortal Kombat annihilation because I
love you you're welcome America
and you guys have been pushing that like
button like I've said before it really
is helping the videos out thus helping
the channel out if you don't completely
hate my guts after that Mortal Kombat
annihilation thing if you can hit that
like button on this video that would
help and I do appreciate it come on it's
a little funny and I'll come on all
right so Godzilla king of the monsters
have you seen it what do you think of it
how does it compare to the 2014 Godzilla
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]